on est avec xavier moreau à présent
directeur de strap paul en direct de
moscou pour décrypter ces deux discours
du président vladimir poutine et du
ministre de la défense qu'en avez-vous
retenu
xavier moreau bond les deux discours on
les été extrêmement dense la première
chose que j'ai retenu moi c'est la
recherche de convergences et ce qui est
à mon avis un point particulièrement
important de la politique étrangère
russe c'est à dire qu'on est on n'est
pas dans une recherche de rapports de
force contrairement à ce qu'on peut voir
du côté de l'otan mais dans une volonté
de trouver localement ou
internationalement une convergence avec
des partenaires potentiels par exemple
l'a dit mercredi n'a parlé et le
ministre choïgou on parlait de la syrie
est là en fait ce problème s'est résolu
en partie grâce à la convergence entre
des pays comptant sont pas forcément les
meilleurs amis du monde c'est à dire la
russie la turquie et l'iran et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est ça qui est
important et les à cette recherche de
convergences vous avez le fait il ya
vous avez la grande absente de ces deux
discours qui est l'idéologie
il n'y a dans les mots de vladimir
poutine nice 2-2 du ministre choïgou
vous n'avez aucune idéologie et donc on
est dans une situation qui est
totalement différente de celle de la
guerre froide vous aviez deux blocs
idéologiques qui se posaient les
démocraties libérales d'un côté et les
démocraties socialiste de l'autre mais
vous avez simplement un pays souverain
qui cherche à construire un système
international reposant sur le droit
international et l'onu dupuis structure
beauté gc frontières évidemment
exactement de toute manière il n'y a pas
de politique étrangère il n'y a pas de
défense de ses intérêts si vous n'avez
pas les moyens le cas échéant d'utiliser
la force pour les protéger donc je pense
que c'est cesser ce point là qui m'a le
qui m'a le plus plu intéressés ainsi le
long développement également sur sur
l'afrique visiblement la politique
étrangère de la russie la politique de
défense et de stabilité internationale
de la russie passe par un soutien à
l'afrique on a vu l'avenir poutine
où c'était un ami très cher bouffon cité
l'algérie cité la guinée donc c'est
évidemment l'algérie et le grand allié
de russie en afrique et c'est là paraît
cela parle également une priorité
ainsi que bien sûr la zone asie
pacifique qui est un nouvel objectif de
l'otan
et là aussi c'est un point important
c'est que et bien l'otan est la seule
alliance militaire internationale qui
est désormais sa saga fuel a également
développé qui n'est plus censé défendre
uniquement le le europe mais est devenue
une alliance 2 mondial donc en fait
c'est la seule alliance au monde
militaire politico-militaire qui est
qu'ils s'en rendent contre le reste du
monde
c'est ça aussi le pensent que le nouveau
paradigme c'est l'otan face au reste du
monde admire poutine qui a insisté aussi
sur le contexte de dégradation de la
sécurité dans le monde particulièrement
critique aujourd'hui puisqu'il n'ya une
autre menace c'est évidemment la
pandémie et et ça va faire l'objet bien
sûr de de nombreuses conférences au
cours de ces deux jours de deux sommets
oui tout à fait en fait là on en revient
bien sûr à la chapelle maintenant la jeu
politique des vaccins c'est à dire est
ce que la pandémie est un moyen pour les
occidentaux d'imposer leur volonté reste
du monde d'imposer leur volonté de
nos soi-disant de brand reset ou est-ce
que eh bien il va donner lieu à une
coopération internationale ou essayer de
juguler et de redevenir et de revenir
non pas un nouveau monde parce que 8 mai
au monde au monde d'avant qui est qui et
qui était bien meilleur donc ce sera un
thème qui je pense sera effectivement
abordé
même si je pense qu'il sera loin
derrière loin derrière les questions de
politique internationale et de défense
de stabilité plutôt classique
si vous voulez les hors jeu les enjeux
mais les enjeux de sécurité nucléaire
sont quand même plus important que la
vie alors justement sur sur la sécurité
et la prolifération des armes
on a vu l'avenir coutume justement
relancer le traité justement sûr sûr sûr
c'est sur ces arbres qui avaient été
arrêtés par donald trump donc on sent
qu'il ya une dynamique après après cette
rencontre avec les états unis
je pense tout à fait et d'ailleurs
vladimir poutine
sans ce site et lui-même mais à
expliquer justement ce problème de
prolifération nucléaire et il a fait une
proposition faite il ya quelques temps
de cela je pense que ça peut payer un an
où il a dit de toute manière il faut
revoir la gestion des armes nucléaires
au niveau global au niveau mondial
pourquoi parce que il ya des événements
classe les pays nucléaires en fonction
de différentes catégories ya ceux qui
ont l'armé nucléaire qui le disent il ya
ce qu'ils ont et qu'ils ne disent pas il
ya ceux qui ne l'ont pas mais qui
pourrait l'obtenir parce que ils ont un
haut niveau de technologie rapidement
émond et il ya ceux qui l'ont qui le
disent mais qui ne rentrent pas dans les
accords de non prolifération comme par
exemple la corée du nord et le dire
poutine il y avait six mois un an a
proposé de remettre tout ça sur la table
c'est à dire de faire une grande grande
conférence internationale sur l'armé
nucléaire pour que tous soient mises à
plat et que notamment des pays bas
qu'auparavant israël possède l'armé
nucléaire est bien le dise et qu'on
essaye justement d éviter toute forme de
prolifération et ça je pense que c'est
un sujet fondamental est effectivement
aussi le fait que paradoxalement pendant
la guerre froide tout le risque de
guerre nucléaire à structurer les
relations est ouest
c'est à dire à l'époque la relation mon
on va dire et il ya toute une série de
traités à partir du début des années 70
qui ont été mis en place et que
l'amérique a commencé à déboulonner à
partir de george bush junior en 2002 où
les sorties justement du traité sur les
armes intermédiaires pour justifier pour
pouvoir permettre le développement de
paris préserve l'intermédiaire des des
missiles antimissiles pour pouvoir
justifier le déploiement sur les
territoires de l'otan ou contrôlées par
les états unis de ces systèmes est donc
d'essayer de faire basculer l'équilibré
l'équilibré entre entre la russie mais
maintenant il mène également la chine et
les états unis au moyen de sa et donc de
sortir de ces structures internationales
qui avaient été mises en place par la
guerre froide pendant la guerre froide
et qui bon an mal an je fonctionnais il
est clair que le souhait aujourd'hui de
l'animé routine c'est de revenir à un
monde règle est régulé avec l'onu au
coeur de cette régulation pivot central
de la stabilité mondiale c'est ce qu'a
rappelé vladimir poutine xavier moreau
très rapidement une dernière question on
a vu un sergueï choïgou a également
insisté sur l'histoire il a demandé une
minute de silence pour les victimes de
la seconde guerre mondiale la russie qui
a commémoré hier justement l'agression
de l'allemagne nazie contre contre l'ex
république soviétique
l'histoire c'est important aussi le fait
de ne pas oublier bien sûr que c'est
important et c'est surtout un très
important pour vladimir poutine qui
d'ailleurs a vient de publier dans la
presse allemande
un grand article historique puisque la
nuit est un féru d'histoire il a écrit
sur les origines de la russie et là il a
fait un grand article où justement il
faisait référence est les cendriers mais
en fait on commémore les 80 ans du début
de l'opération barbarossa donc de
l'allemagne nazie contre contre l'union
soviétique
et justement l'idée de convergence on la
retrouve dans ce dans ce discours c'est
à dire que vous m'avez vous nous avez
peut-être pas mais nous avons des
intérêts communs donc cesser de
rechercher rapport de force avec nous et
au nom de ses intérêts communs comme pas
par exemple le nord stream 2 qui est
typique de la diplomatie russe est à
dire qu il ya un intérêt commun
utilisons le pur pour aller de l'avant
de notre relation
aucune relation extrêmement riche
ea idéologiques ont ceci c'est encore
une fois c'est quelque chose de très
important c'est que alors que les pays
occidentaux soient encore dans l'idée de
d'imposer leur idéologie au reste du
monde et bien la russie elle est dans
une vision tout à fait je dirais presque
viennoise au sens du traité de vienne de
1815 de recherche de stabilité avec et
bien principalement les grandes
puissances avec l'allemagne nous
n'imposons jamais notre volonté aux
autres pays voilà une des phrases qui
est aussi été prononcées par vladimir
poutine ce matin merci beaucoup
xavier moreau je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur de stratton merci d'avoir
décrypter cette début de conférence avec
nous